جولزرين يعيش مع اسرته على بعد امتار من
قصر الرئاسه في العاصمه كابول في هذه
المنازل الطينيه المتواضعه التي لا تقي
برد الشتاء اسرته بلزارين تعكس الحياه في
القرى الافغانيه التي يعيش فيها معظم
الشعب الافغاني
يقولذرين انه اطفاله السته جمعا
البلاستيكه وقطعا من الحطب في الشوارع
للتدفئه في هذا الشتاء
وفصل الشتاء سوف يمر علينا بدون اي وسائل
تدفئه كما ترى هناك قليل من البلاستيك
وليست عندنا وسائل اخرى للتدفئه
عائله فاطمه هي الاخرى التي تعيش في
العاصمه كابول قتل زوجها في عمليه تفجيريه
وهي كفيفه لديها خمسه من الاطفال الصغار
تقول ان جيرانها ساعدوها لتشتري كميه من
الفحم لا تكفيهم لاسبوع تشرح بالقليل منه
لتدفئه اطفالها
الجيران يساعدوننا احيانا ببعض الحطب
واحيانا كثيره لا ونحن في اكثر الاوقات لا
نحصل على التدفئه كيس واحد من الفحم لا
يكفي بالنسبه لطول الشتاء
والتي توصف بالطبقه الثريه في افغانستان
فانها تعتمد على وسائل التدفئه مريحه لا
تخرج دخان ولا تحدث ازعاجا تشتغل اكثر
بالحطب وبعضها بالوقود ولكننا نفقاتها
باهظه
اصول الشتاء طويل
همم
وهي جيده ونقوم بها في حرق الحطب ونشكر
الله على هذه الوسائل فان الشتاء في
افغانستان قارس جدا وقد اعلن مكتب الامم
المتحده لتنسيق المساعدات الانسانيه اوتشا
ان 79% من سكان افغانستان يعيشون في ملاجئ
مؤقته ومنازل الشبه مدمره هذا الشتاء فصل
الشتاء في افغانستان بارد وممطر مليء
بالمصاعد في وقت تحذر المؤسسات الامميه من
الشيطان الحالي سيكون تحديا اضافيا
لتحديات اليوميه للشعب الافغاني عبد
المنذر العربيه كابول